>> IT WOULD BE COOLER IF YOU
DID.
>> Laura: AT FIRST WE WERE
JUST TOLD THAT IT WAS JUST GOING
TO HELP PEOPLE COPING WITH
SERIOUS ILLNESSES, THEN WE WERE
TOLD IT WAS JUST TO RELIEVE
PAIN.
THEN, WE WERE TOLD IT WAS FOR
LEGAL ADULTS AND NO WORSE THAN
ALCOHOL.
BUT NOW COLORADO WANTS HER TO
GET TO A WHOLE NEW LEVEL.
FRUSTRATED BY THE MORE MODERATE
JOHN HICKENLOOPER’S PUSH FOR
LEGALIZATION, THEY WANT TO PASS
A BILL TO BE ALLOWING POT
DELIVERY RIGHT TO YOUR FRONT
DOOR.
HERE TO DEBATE IT IS
REPRESENTATIVE JONATHAN SINGER,
AND AND WHY MAKE IT EASIER FOR
FOLKS TO GET AT THEIR HANDS ON
POT.
>> IN 2012 MARIJUANA SAID IT
WOULD BE LEGAL, CONSTITUTIONAL,
AND THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE GOING UP
ON CRAIGSLIST DELIVERING
MARIJUANA TO PEOPLE’S DOORS AND
NOT CARING ABOUT WHAT WAS ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE DOOR.
IS IT A KID, AN ADULT?
WE DON’T KNOW.
NOW IT’S TIME TO TAKE IT OUT OF
THE SHADOWS AND REGULATE IT JUST
LIKE ALCOHOL.
MAKE SURE WE LICENSE OUR
DRIVERS, GET THEM TRACKED BY GPS
AND MAKE SURE WE ARE NOT SELLING
TO KIDS.
>> Laura: LEGAL LEGALIZATION
HAS NOT LIMITED THE TRADE IN
COLORADO.
AND WE HAVE THAT MINOR
INCONVENIENCE THAT IT’S STILL A
FEDERAL CRIME.
SO YOU WANT TO MAKE IT LEGAL TO
FACILITATE AN ONGOING FEDERAL
CRIME WITH THE DELIVERY OF POT
TO THE DOORSTEP.
>> IT’S EVEN MORE IMPORTANT TO
STAMP OUT A BLACK MARKET.
>> Laura: THAT WAS STAMPED OUT
WITH MARIJUANA IN GENERAL.
>> THAT’S BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
FULLY REGULATING IT LIKE WE
SHOULD BE.
>> I LIVED IN COLORADO MY WHOLE
LIFE AND WE’VE SEEN THE BLACK
MARKET ACTUALLY THRIVE IN THE
"LEGALIZED" STATE OF COLORADO.
COLORADO IS NOW THE NUMBER ONE
EXPORTER OF BLACK MARKET
MARIJUANA AND WE HAVE
INTERNATIONAL CARTELS THAT ARE
BUYING UP SUBURBAN HOUSES,
TURNING THEM INTO GROW HOUSES
AND SHIPPING MARIJUANA ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
THERE IS A MAJOR IMPACT IN THE
BLACK MARKET WHEN YOU LAY GUYS
AND IT DOESN’T GO AWAY LIKE WE
WERE TOLD.
BLACK-MARKET IS AN ISSUE BUT THE
REAL ISSUE IS TODAY, THE OWNER
OF MARLBOROUGH AND PHILIP
MORRIS, A MAJOR MEGA MILLION
DOLLAR TOBACCO COMPANY JUST
BOUGHT A $1.8 BILLION TAKEN A
MARIJUANA COMPANY.
>> IT’S ABOUT MONEY, THEY ARE
MAKING MILLIONS.
WHEN JOHN BOEHNER WHO USED TO BE
AGAINST LEGALIZING WEED, HE IS
LIKE I HAD A CHANGE OF HEART,
WELL HOW MUCH MONEY IS ON THE
BOARD THAT YOU SAY YOU ARE A
CONSULTANT ON?
LET’S SAY THIS IS ALL FOR
REGULATING AND WE WANT TO MAKE
EVERYTHING SAFE, THIS IS ABOUT
BIG MONEY.
IF THERE WEREN’T BILLIONS IN
THIS, WE WOULDN’T BE TALKING
ABOUT IT.
AND THEN MAYBE ASK A QUESTION,
IS IT GOOD FOR ESPECIALLY YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ARE USING THIS IN
GREATER NUMBERS TODAY BECAUSE OF
THE OVERALL LEGALIZATION PUSH,
TURNING IT EARLIER, AND HAVING
MORE DEVELOPMENTAL PROBLEMS AS A
RESULT.
NOT TO LOOK AT OLDER PEOPLE BUT
THE YOUNG DEVELOPING BRAIN,
ET CETERA DISASTER TO START
SMOKING POT OR INGESTING POT AT
AN EARLY AGE.
>> THAT’S WHERE ALL THREE OF US
WILL AGREE.
THIS IS NOT FOR KIDS, AND UNLESS
YOU ARE TALKING TO A DOCTOR,
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT COULD
SHOULD BE HAVING.
THE BILL WE RAN LAST YEAR WAS
SUPPORTED BY A LIBERTARIAN
REPUBLICAN.
AND IF EVERYTHING HAPPENED IN A
VACUUM THEN GREAT.
AND DEATHS RELATED TO MARIJUANA
HAVE DOUBLED IN COLORADO.
>> Laura: HOW WOULD THAT WORK
ON THE DELIVERY?
PLAY IT OUT FOR ME.
PLAY IT OUT ON LIKE AN UBER
STYLE WEBSITE, OR YOUR APP, JUST
FOR POT.
OR WOULD IT BE, UBER DRIVERS
COULD ALSO THEMSELVES DELIVER
IT?
I’M NOT FOLLOWING HOW THAT WOULD
WORK.
>> FIRST OF ALL IMPAIRED DRIVING
IS INCREDIBLY SERIOUS.
I HAVE BEEN TO THE FUNERAL OF A
FRIEND OF MINE WHO LOST A
STEPDAUGHTER TO A DRIVER WHO
WASN’T PAIRED WITH BOTH ALCOHOL
AND MARIJUANA.
OUR LAWS ARE NOT STRONG ENOUGH.
THE WAY THIS WORKS, YOU DIAL
SOMETHING UP AND YOU HAVE A
LICENSED GPS TO ATTRACT PERSON
SHOWS UP.